is there anything that you can share
that maybe you would have you know given
yourself advice on if a client's going
to engage with you you then want to book
in like a proper time slot with them so
you want to have a video call or in
person meet I think that's imperative I
still will sometimes have like mini
scripts of certain questions that I want
to ask a client like I think it's really
important especially when you're
starting off to almost have that script
and just be like these are the questions
I'm going to ask put some curveballs in
there as well I'd feedback to your
client and say the Market's really
competitive it will be great to go a bit
more in depth like what's going to sell
you what's your culture like why do you
like working there